on à rodolphe thomas qui est avec nous
merci rodolphe thomas d'être là vous
êtes maire d'hérouville saint clair dans
le calvados et vous regardez vous avez
appelé
voilà vous avez fait appel à vous à vos
habitants à ne pas hésiter à appeler la
police lorsqu'ils voient une incivilité
devant leurs yeux regarder si vous avez
bon jour à tout
bonjour à tous je sais que les règles de
confinement qui s'adressent à nous
aujourd'hui ne sont pas respectées par
tous les directives du gouvernement sont
claires pour préserver nos familles nos
amis et nos voisins
il est obligatoire que nous restions
confient les chez nous désormais toute
infraction est passible d'une amende de
135 euros et la police nationale tout
comme la police municipale ferons
appliquer toutes les mesures en
direction de ceux qui ne respecteront
pas les consignes telles que
l'interdiction des regroupements sur
l'espace public pour tout signalement
n'hésitez pas à contacter la police
nationale au 17
voilà alors merci d'être avec nous
rodolphe thomas maire de mont saint
hilaire du calvados merci beaucoup
alors monsieur le maire injuste vous
avez fait cet appel dont pourront dit
voilà où il est fait un appel à dénoncer
voilà ceux qui commettent des
incivilités
c'est pas à l'énoncé cyril sebas la fois
social vous faisiez pas dénoncer
délation ses combats en appelant en
demandant aux français d'appeler le 17
on est sûr de la délation enfin moi ça
fait 20 ans que je suis maire
d'hérouxville à aucun moment j'ai amené
à appeler à chaque fois le 17 on est là
sur véritablement de la prévention et de
la sensibilisation auprès de l'ensemble
de celles et ceux qui ne respectent pas
effectivement les règles de confinement
donc c'est parti sur sincèrement ce sera
un bon sentiment de la appelé de
l'appellation gens mais dire excusez moi
nous ramons temps donc
et tout ça c'est venu la vidéo vous avez
fait passer à l'instant elle est en fait
allé presque plus dix jours après la
situation parce que beaucoup de
gens se plaignent et qui était
effectivement respectées le confinement
et voyant beaucoup de personnes sortir
surtout au pied des immeubles
moi j'étais plus axé sur des cartes ou
et effectivement il ya des grosses
difficultés de squat de des différentes
délinquance au pied des immeubles
et ce sont les habitants qui on veut
dire nous on est confiné et vous laisser
certains types bien certain sens surtout
ne seront par les deux des familles que
vous avez cités tout à leur banque
moi j'essaye en compte le maire
d'assumer cette responsabilité plus dans
le cadre de la sensibilisation et de la
prévention
mais pour apporter dans certains moments
certains quartiers un peu de respect du
cadre de vie
sur l'ensemble comment dirais-je des
pieds d'immeubles donc c'est mon rôle en
tant que maire mais j'ai surtout pas
voulu froisser
enfin la ligue des droits de l'homme à
aucun moment ça me faisait régner de
parler de délation
enfin je là je m'en remets à la alors à
bien par rooney avait besoin